friends you are perfection personified
your smile brings light to all those by
your side my darkest secrets I can
confide with you my true self I never
have to hide I snap I moan I forget to
phone I fear my love for you isn't often
shown but you're impossible to forget
you've helped shaped me from the day we
first met
I'm so grateful for the seeds that I've
sown the only ones I love without worry
of threat family because of you I came
to be I proudly carried traits of you
with me and when I fall down to my knees
it's on you I relied to never leave you
taught me how to live and laugh and then
waved me off on my own path but through
the years we've collected stains that
cannot be washed away by blame please
stop soaking in this shame filled bath
because I still love you just the same
you
without knowing your face or name left
shrouded in darkness you became my flame
fingers typing leaves my energy but
gained a stranger's input to spur on my
brain doubt starts creeping with
thoughts so vile but with kind words
flowing I can't help but smile you're
the ones who give me hope you keep me
treading of this slope we're sharing
dreams is always worthwhile when mankind
proves their kindness devote to the ones
who can do no wrong to the ones who keep
me burning strong and to the ones who
keep me moving on you make my life
something to be proud of with your
wisdom joy and your love thank you
[Music]
the
[Music]
you